This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二的绝对真人。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听数字2。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人群体的男性经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全但却必须坦诚的对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们的含义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s.
对于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身处世界何地。非常高兴你们能来到这里，收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理学。
Being criticized, whether it's at work, by a partner, by a friend, on the internet, it is never a pleasant experience. It can leave us, I would say, quite indignant, quite angry, shocked, embarrassed. Maybe you want to hide away. Maybe you're quite anxious. You're thinking that someone is disappointed in you. Someone doesn't like you.
遭到批评，无论是在工作中、由伴侣、由朋友、还是在互联网上，都绝对不是一次愉快的体验。可以说，这会让我们感到相当愤慨、相当愤怒、震惊、尴尬。也许你想躲起来。也许你相当焦虑。你会觉得有人对你失望。有人不喜欢你。
I think it's only fair that we have that reaction. Our ego can be quite fragile. It's quite a sensitive being. And it's sensitive and fragile because it's trying to protect us. But sometimes what our ego thinks is best actually isn't helpful. being able to take what you need from feedback and override that immediate emotional reaction can actually provide us with so much knowledge, so much information, so much power. And it's why I think that we need a new approach to handling criticism that doesn't essentially
我认为我们有这种反应是很公平的。我们的自我可能相当脆弱。它是一个相当敏感的存在。它之所以敏感而脆弱，是因为它在试图保护我们。但有时我们自我认为最好的东西实际上并没有帮助。能够从反馈中获取你需要的东西并克服那种即时的情绪反应，实际上可以为我们提供如此多的知识、如此多的信息、如此多的力量。这就是为什么我认为我们需要一种处理批评的新方法，这种方法本质上
throw out the baby with the bathwater. And that is exactly what we are going to discuss today. The biggest reason personally, this is just my opinion, but the biggest reason I find that people struggle with criticism and I will include myself in that category is because we don't understand our reaction to it. We tend to only process criticism emotionally rather than logically and that means that it becomes a highly tense kind of situation rather than one that is quite neutral. Alongside that, you know, for those of us who are naturally just more sensitive to criticism or we feel like our sensitivity is a fault that we have, we actually tend to get into the cycle of avoiding feedback at all
不会把洗澡水和婴儿一起泼掉。而这正是我们今天要讨论的内容。就我个人而言，这只是我的意见，我发现人们难以面对批评的最大原因——我也把自己归入这一类——是因为我们不理解自己对批评的反应。我们往往只是凭情绪而不是从逻辑上去处理批评，这意味着这变成了一种高度紧张的情况，而不是一种相当中立的情况。除此之外，你知道，对于我们那些天生对批评更敏感的人，或者我们觉得自己的敏感是一个缺点的人，我们实际上往往会陷入不惜一切代价逃避反馈的循环中
costs, whether that's in our jobs or in our relationships, instead of really understanding why it is that we personally feel so intense about it and why it is that we feel the need to avoid feedback. I think understanding where your aversion and your hypersensitivity comes from, because it is something that some of us are almost just born with, and, you know, understanding why that's the case or if you weren't born with it, whether it came from a hypercritical upbringing, a past relationship, a fear of rejection, I think that can be really empowering. And the same goes for really anything that we discuss. When you understand the origins and you have the knowledge and the information to understand your brain and your personality
无论是在工作中还是在人际关系中，而不是真正去理解为什么我们个人对它感觉如此强烈，以及为什么我们觉得有必要逃避反馈。我认为理解你的厌恶感和高度敏感从何而来——因为这确实是我们中有些人几乎生来就有的，而且，你知道，理解为什么会这样，或者如果你不是生来如此，它是否源于过于挑剔的成长环境、过去的关系、对被拒绝的恐惧——我认为这会赋予人强大的力量。我们讨论的任何话题也是如此。当你了解了起源，并且拥有了理解你的大脑、你的个性
and your reactions better, suddenly the thing that felt very dangerous and scary and hostile to you because become something that you can kind of know better. So we're also going to talk through how we can develop a healthy approach to feedback, how we can hold space for both our emotional and our logical reaction. And also, when you actually don't need to listen to someone's feedback, when you don't need to listen to someone's criticism, let me just say as someone who works on the internet, there are a lot of people who want to pass pretty cruel judgments.
以及你的反应所需的知识和信息时，突然之间，那个让你感到非常危险、可怕和充满敌意的东西，就变成了一种你可以更深入了解的事物。所以我们还将探讨如何培养对反馈的健康态度，如何为我们的情感和逻辑反应留出空间。还有，什么时候你其实根本不需要听取别人的反馈，什么时候你根本不需要听取别人的批评。请允许我作为一名在互联网上工作的人说一句，有很多人喜欢做出相当残酷的评判。
and those individuals and those situations aren't, you know, they're just, they are not worth a second of your time. They are not worth it. And sometimes I think our hatred of criticism and feedback comes because we see all criticism as being this very cruel, negative thing. But there is a distinction, an important one, and I want to give you an easy method for figuring it out. It is a big episode today, folks. it's definitely, I think one that I'm going to come back to multiple times when I need it. So I hope that you learn something. I hope that we can dive into all the psychology that you're wanting to know,
而这些个人和那些情况，你知道，它们根本不值得你花费哪怕一秒钟的时间。它们不值得。有时我认为我们对批评和反馈的厌恶，是因为我们将所有的批评都视为这种非常残酷、消极的事情。但它们之间是有区别的，这是一个重要的区别，我想给你一个简单的方法来弄清楚这一点。伙计们，今天是一期内容丰富的节目。它绝对是我在需要时会多次回看的一期节目，我想是这样的。所以我希望你能学到一些东西。我希望我们能深入探讨你想要了解的所有心理学，
all the research behind this ubiquitous topic, this topic of criticism. Without further ado, let's get into it. I'm going to go out there and make a pretty huge statement to begin with that not a single person on this planet likes being criticized. even the people who claim to or who are like seemingly open to feedback they welcome it let me just say no matter how often you are criticized no matter how used to what you are it still stinks because human nature is to almost feel a little bit threatened or to bristle when you seemingly are criticized or are put down or your mistakes are revealed even those of us with the thickest skin we will still wince at hearing that someone is displeased, doesn't like our work, find some fault with our character, disagrees with our behaviour. I want to make it very, very clear that that is quite a natural reaction. Interestingly, I think that's also the reason why we sometimes hold
关于这个无处不在的话题、关于批评这个话题的所有研究。闲话少说，让我们切入正题。首先我要做一个相当宏大的声明，那就是这个星球上没有一个人喜欢被批评。即使是那些声称喜欢或似乎对反馈持开放态度、欢迎反馈的人——请容许我说一句，无论你受到批评的频率有多高，无论你对它多么习以为常，它依然很糟糕。因为人性几乎就是这样：当你似乎受到批评、被看低或你的错误被揭露时，你会感到有些受威胁或本能地竖起浑身刺。即使是我们这些脸皮最厚的人，在听到有人不高兴、不喜欢我们的工作、发现我们性格上有某些缺陷、不同意我们的行为时，也仍然会退缩。我想非常非常清楚地表明，这是一种相当自然的反应。有趣的是，我认为这也是有时我们有所保留的原因
off from giving constructive criticism to others as well. You know, you've got a friend who's like pissed you off or a co-worker who continually frustrates you and you complain about it to your friends over and over again, but you know you're never going to say anything. Because part of it is that we have empathy for the pain and the sting that is created by criticism. We don't want to put someone else at the receiving end of that. And maybe in a similar vein, we don't want someone to then throw criticism back at us. If you want a really cool stuff, detailing this, there was a series of three experiments conducted a couple years ago, and basically the research has put around 1,200 participants through this real-time scenario,
而没有向其他人提出建设性批评。你知道，你有一个朋友惹恼了你，或者一个同事不断让你沮丧，你向朋友一遍又一遍地抱怨，但你知道你永远不会说什么。因为部分原因在于我们对批评所带来的痛苦和刺痛感有着同理心。我们不想让别人成为这种感受的承受者。也许出于同样的原因，我们也不希望别人反过来对我们进行批评。如果你想要一些真正很酷、详细说明这一点的资料，几年前曾进行过一系列三个实验，基本上研究让大约1200名参与者经历了这个实时场景，
where they were asked to complete a survey. And the survey was actually being administered by someone who was a member of the research team. And as they're completing the survey, you know, the participant would look up and see that the person who was observing them, who was conducting the survey, had food on their face or had lipstick on their teeth. And it was very, very obvious. And out of those 1,200 participants, only about four of them said anything. No one wants to be the critic, even if we think it might be helpful, because it's awkward to say, you know, I've noticed something about you that is embarrassing or unappealing or unappealing. and I think it's our like empathy for someone else and knowing that if we were in their shoes,
他们被要求完成一项调查。而这项调查实际上是由研究团队的一名成员主持的。当他们完成调查时，你知道，参与者会抬头看到正在观察他们、主持调查的人脸上沾了食物或者牙齿上有口红。而且非常非常明显。在这1200名参与者中，只有大约四个人说了出来。没有人想当批评者，即使我们认为这可能会有帮助，因为说出口很尴尬，你知道的，我注意到你身上有些令人尴尬、缺乏吸引力或不讨喜的事情。而且我认为我们对别人的同理心让我们觉得，如果我们设身处地为他们着想的话，
we would feel deeply embarrassed and awkward. So criticism, like, whilst it might be helpful, we have this weird relationship with it. The reason that we truly hate criticism, though, stems from our ego. You may have already guessed that. Now, when people hear ego, often they conflate it with arrogance, right? You know, someone who was high and mighty, who was full of themselves, who believes that they very impressive. They have a big ego. But actually, our ego isn't about our self-opinion. It kind of is, but it's more about how we mediate our internal feelings with what's happening
我们会感到深深的尴尬和局促。所以批评，虽然它可能是有帮助的，但我们与它有着一种奇怪的关系。不过，我们真正讨厌批评的原因源于我们的自我。你可能已经猜到了。现在，当人们听到“自我”这个词时，往往会把它与傲慢混为一谈，对吧？你知道，那种高高在上、自以为是、认为自己非常了不起的人。他们有着巨大的自我。但实际上，我们的自我并不是关于我们的自我评价。某种程度上算是吧，但它更多的是关于我们如何将内部感受与发生在
in the outside world or externally. And this was Freud's original idea of ego. He was the, I don't like to say creator or the founder. He was the discoverer maybe of ego. And how he saw it was that it was a control center for our self-esteem. name and its job was to basically integrate what other people might say about us, their opinions, the feedback that we're getting, and what we believe about ourselves, basically pulling us into check. It is responsible for maintaining a sense of self. And when we receive criticism, this is of course seen as a threat to that very sense of self. We have a natural desire to feel good, to feel good about ourselves, to think that we're the shit.
外部世界的事情进行调解。这就是弗洛伊德最初的自我概念。他不是——我不喜欢说创造者或创始人。他可能是自我的发现者。他是如何看待它的呢，它是一个我们自尊心的控制中心。它的工作基本上是整合其他人可能对我们的看法、他们的意见、我们得到的反馈以及我们对自己的信念，基本上让我们保持清醒。它负责维持一种自我感。而当我们受到批评时，这当然被视为对那种自我感的威胁。我们有一种自然的渴望，想要感觉良好，对自我感觉良好，认为自己很牛。
and therefore there is like a natural discomfort that comes with the insecurity and the negativity they often accompanies criticism. So, you know, when your boss says, well, that's not really what I was after or a friend tells you that they're upset with how you behaved and they really think that you should think about your actions or some internet troll says you look ugly, you know, or says you have an annoying voice. I don't know. Maybe I'm projecting.
因此，伴随着批评而来的往往是不安全感和消极情绪，这就带来了一种天然的不适感。所以，你知道，当你的老板说“嗯，这其实不是我想要的”，或者一个朋友告诉你他们对你的行为感到不安，他们真的认为你应该反思自己的行为，或者某个网络喷子说你长得很丑，你知道的，或者说你的声音很烦人。我不知道。也许我在投射。
But basically, in those situations, our immediate reaction is to be quite agitated, to feel threatened and to feel upset, because our unconscious defense mechanism is to protect our ego. And the way that we do this is kind of detaching from the criticism or maybe even finding a way to lessen it. This may include, you know, discrediting the person who is criticizing you, like, you know, why would I listen to them? Like, I don't respect them and therefore their judgment becomes.
但基本上，在这些情况下，我们的即时反应是感到相当烦躁、感到受到威胁和感到不安，因为我们的无意识防御机制是为了保护我们的自我。而我们这样做的方式有点像与批评保持距离，或者甚至寻找一种方法来减轻它。这可能包括，你知道，诋毁那个批评你的人，比如，你知道，我为什么要听他们的？——我不尊重他们，因此他们的判断就变得
less important. We also justify our mistake or our behavior based on the context. We might ruminate over it. We might take it incredibly. Personally, we might withdraw. Or we can actually use the criticism as motivation. We can engage in some reflective, selective processing and take the positive parts on board. That is 100% the scenario that we want. But is, is a lot of the scenario that we want. But is it the scenario that happens? Not really. Not all the time. It honestly takes practice to have a healthy approach to criticism,
不那么重要了。我们也会根据语境为我们的错误或行为辩护。我们可能会对此反复思量。我们可能会把它看作针对个人的。我们可能会退缩。或者我们实际上可以将批评作为动力。我们可以进行一些反思性的、有选择性的加工，把积极的部分听进去。这百分之百是我们想要的场景。但这，是我们想要的场景吗？其实不然。并非总是如此。老实说，需要练习才能对批评采取健康的态度，
which is naturally a lot harder for some, especially if you are someone who is highly rejection sensitive or just sensitive in general. Criticism, even when it's constructive, can feel a lot like rejection because it can be perceived as someone saying that they are displeased with you, that they dislike you, and whilst it's only normally about some small thing, something that's maybe even arbitrary, when you are someone who is quite sensitive to rejection, you take that small thing and you make it huge.
而这对于某些人来说自然要困难得多，特别是如果你是一个对拒绝高度敏感或仅仅是总体上很敏感的人。批评，即使是建设性的，也会让人感觉很像拒绝，因为它可能被感知为某人在说他们对你不满、他们不喜欢你。虽然这通常只是一些小事，甚至是随意的小事，但当你是一个对拒绝相当敏感的人时，你就会把这件小事放大成大事。
And it makes you start to believe that maybe they don't like you as a whole. This is, of course, faulty thinking. But if you do have that intense rejection sensitivity, you cannot override that first thought. it is very, very hard to not follow your instinct. This rejection sensitivity, it's really, really common if you're someone with ADHD, because we know that ADHD often leads to hyperfixation, meaning that we get stuck on this point of criticism, we cannot break away, but it also makes us harder to, it makes it harder for us to regulate our emotions
这让你开始相信，也许他们整体上并不喜欢你。这当然是错误的思维。但如果你确实有那种强烈对拒绝的敏感，你就无法覆盖那种最初的想法。要做到不顺从自己的本能是非常非常困难的。这种拒绝敏感，如果你患有ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍），真的非常非常普遍，因为我们知道ADHD通常会导致过度专注，这意味着我们会卡在批评的这个点上，无法自拔，但它也让我们更难，让我们更难调节自己的情绪
towards particularly upsetting situations. And this is one of them. Obviously, you don't have to have ADHD to be quite reject. action sensitive, but there is quite a, quite a connection. The result of this, though, is quite extreme and it often looks really extreme to others. You know, maybe they can, they get a bit frustrated with criticism and then they can sweep it under the rug or they can just move on. But if you're someone who's quite sensitive to it, you're going to suddenly have really intense anxiety around the situation. You might not want to see that person again. You might avoid them. There's extreme
面对特别令人沮丧的情况。而这就是其中之一。显然，你不需要患有ADHD也会对拒绝相当敏感，但这两者之间确实有着相当大的联系。不过，这种结果往往非常极端，对其他人来说看起来真的很极端。你知道，也许他们对批评会感到有点沮丧，然后他们可以把这件事抛在脑后或者直接继续前进。但如果你是一个对批评相当敏感的人，你就会突然对这种情况产生非常强烈的焦虑。你可能不想再见到那个人。你可能会避开他们。会有极端的
sadness, anger, not being able to stop talking about it, even when you can tell that other people are moving on, that kind of thing. Actually, it can be really annoying because I think some part of you might know that it's not that deep, right? You know, the person was just trying to help. You have your excuses, you have your reasons, and you want to handle it positively. But that rational approach is, once again, overridden by a deep anxiety, a deep fear, a deeply ingrained instinct. I actually think I see this most often in relationships, because obviously when it comes to love, when it comes to connection, there is so much to lose. When we care about something a lot, any criticism related to that thing always seems to
悲伤、愤怒、无法停止谈论它，即使你能看出其他人已经在向前看了，诸如此类的事情。实际上，这可能会非常烦人，因为我认为你的一部分可能知道事情没有那么严重，对吧？你知道，那个人只是想帮忙。你有你的借口，你有你的理由，你想以积极的方式处理它。但那种理性的方法，再一次被深深的焦虑、深深的恐惧、根深蒂固的本能所覆盖。我实际上认为我在亲密关系中最常看到这一点，因为很明显，当谈到爱、当谈到连接时，有太多的东西可能会失去。当我们非常在乎某样东西时，与该东西相关的任何批评似乎总是
take on higher stakes and it takes on a new level of importance because we don't want to lose them. We don't want to lose our partner or our boyfriend or our friend or our girlfriend. So, you know, if your partner is like providing you with feedback after a fight or they say, you know, I don't like how we went about that. I don't like how you did that. I don't like how that made me feel. Your brain is going to take that and go, okay, so is this a bigger problem? Is this indicating something more that I'm not saying?
承载着更高的风险，并提升到一个新的重要级别，因为我们不想失去他们。我们不想失去我们的伴侣、男友、朋友或女友。所以，你知道，如果你的伴侣在争吵后向你提供反馈，或者他们说，你知道，我不喜欢我们处理这件事的方式。我不喜欢你那样做。我不喜欢那让我感觉到的方式。你的大脑会把这些吸收进去，然后想，好吧，那这是一个更大的问题吗？这是否暗示了某些我没有说出来的更多事情？
seeing, are they going to break up with me? You see how the fear spiral goes? You know, I used to be someone like this because I think I had a real fairy tale image of love where the other person, the person you're with, adores you and they adore everything about you and you can do no wrong. And so criticism made me feel like, okay, so obviously we're not meant to be together because true love is meant to be perfect. Very short-sided. I think the other reason why criticism and relationships was something that I was particularly sensitive towards was because my first boyfriend would always criticize me to kind of push me away when he didn't want to speak to me for a few days. Like he would, it was almost like he would deliberately get mad so that I would
看到没，他们是不是要跟我分手？你知道恐惧的螺旋是怎么运作的吗？你知道的，我以前也是这样的人，因为我觉得我对爱情有着非常童话般的幻想，那就是另一个人，也就是你身边的这个人，他会崇拜你，崇拜你的一切，你做什么都是对的。所以批评让我觉得，好吧，很显然我们注定不能在一起，因为真爱应该是完美的。这真的很短视。我想，批评在感情中让我尤为敏感的另一个原因，是因为我的第一任男友总是批评我，以此来把我推开，每当他有几天不想跟我说话的时候。比如他会，几乎就像是他故意生气，好让我
not want to see him so that he could have space and he would time it, time when he wanted space with the criticism, right? You know, it's crazy the things that we tolerate at any point, but especially when we're younger. And over time, I think I became to realize that it really created a complex for me that criticism is something that can be weaponized. And it always has some ulterior motive to it. This person wants to hurt my feelings.
不想见他，这样他就能有自己的空间，而且他会算准时间，用批评来配合他想要空间的时间，对吧？你知道的，我们曾经在任何时候都能容忍那些事情，尤其是当我们还年轻的时候，这真的很疯狂。随着时间的推移，我觉得我开始意识到，这真的给我留下了一种情结，那就是批评是一种可以被武器化的东西。而且它总是带着某种不可告人的动机。这个人想要伤害我的感情。
This person wants to get away with something. There is no way that they could be helpful. Here is the thing that I have since learned. And hopefully you already know, but if not, listen, listen up. I think feedback in any relationship is actually one of the key ingredients. It's super important. I actually personally now believe that a relationship can't survive without it. And you know my saying, I think you don't truly know someone
这个人想要逃避某些责任。它根本不可能是出于好意。这就是我后来学到的事情。希望你已经知道了，如果没有，听好了，仔细听。我认为任何关系中的反馈其实都是关键要素之一。这超级重要。我个人现在甚至认为，没有反馈，一段关系就无法维系。你知道我的口头禅，我觉得你并不真正了解一个人
until you've had to have hard, vulnerable discussions about something that you would rather avoid. Criticism is part of it. The alternative to that, and the alternative to not bringing up your concerns in a constructive way, constructive being the key word here, is resentment. And I think that resentment is a much more toxic addition to a relationship than feedback. Resentment will poison everything. Feedback might just injure your ego.
直到你不得不就那些你宁愿逃避的事情进行艰难而脆弱的讨论。批评只是其中的一部分。而它的替代方案，也就是不以建设性的方式提出你的担忧（建设性是这里的关键词），就是怨恨。我认为，相比于反馈，怨恨对一段关系的毒害要大得多。怨恨会腐蚀一切。反馈或许只会伤害你的自尊。
To me as well, the reason that I think we need to be more accepting of constructive criticism is that it shows that you are prepared to fight for something. It shows that even if it's uncomfortable, you actually want things to get better. You want, you know, this other person wants you to improve. They want you in their life, in their workplace, in their friendship circle, in wherever. But again, there is that sensitivity such that, you know,
对我也一样，我认为我们需要更能接受建设性批评的原因在于，它表明你准备为某事去争取。它表明，即便这让人感到不适，你也确实希望事情变得更好。你希望，你知道的，另一个人希望你变得更好。他们希望你在他们的生活、职场、朋友圈或者任何地方都变得更好。但同样地，那种敏感依然存在，以至于你知道的，
even the most kindest, gentlest of statements can grow teeth and hair and become monstrous in our minds. So there's one final reason or contributor to that sensitivity that I want to mention. And it has to do with family and criticism in childhood. I don't think there is a single episode where I do not reference childhood wounds in some form or another. But it is a huge factor when it comes to our relationship with feedback. I'm going to ask a question here. Or just kind of a hypothetical.
哪怕是最善良、最温柔的言语，在我们的脑海里也会长出牙齿和头发，变得面目可憎。所以，我想提及导致这种敏感的最后一个原因或推手。这与家庭以及童年的批评有关。我觉得几乎没有哪一期节目我是不以某种形式提及童年创伤的。但这确实是我们与反馈建立关系时的一个巨大影响因素。在这里我要问一个问题。或者说只是一个假设。
Have you ever met a parent or like witnessed a mom or a dad? dad who was just so insanely critical of their child and will not cut them some slack. Like their child meaning, you know, under the age of 12 even. So I've got a story about this. I used to babysit these kids. And, okay, I'm going to be quite critical myself here, but their parents were a lesson in everything I did not want to do when I raised my children. Everything was about grades.
你有没有见过哪个父母，或者目睹过某个爸爸妈妈，对自己的孩子极其严苛，一点也不肯放过他们？这里的意思是指他们的孩子，甚至还不到12岁。关于这个我有个故事。我以前帮别人照看孩子。好吧，我在这里也要狠狠地批判一下，他们的父母简直就是我教育孩子时绝对不想效仿的活生生的反面教材。一切都是为了成绩。
Everything was about routine. meeting their expectations and if they didn't they would literally put their children down in front of me. I remember once so there were three children and the mother said in front of me and her three kids pointing to one of the children that he was just going to have to work harder because he was the dumb one. Literally said that in front of me in front of her child and I was gobsmacked. Honestly I wish I'd had a bit more of a spine to say something but I was quite young at the time and it just literally was it was insane to me. These kinds of hypercritical parents we know now can lead to such a shame cycle when it comes
一切都是为了例行公事，为了达到他们的期望。如果没达到，他们就会当着我的面贬低自己的孩子。我记得有一次，当时有三个孩子，母亲当着我和她三个孩子的面，指着其中一个孩子说，他只能加倍努力，因为他是那个最笨的。她真的是当着我的面、当着她孩子的面这么说的，当时我都惊呆了。老实说，我真希望自己当时能更有骨气一点，说点什么，但我那时还挺年轻，这对我来说简直太疯狂了。我们现在知道，这种吹毛求疵的父母会导致什么样的羞耻循环
to feedback. And there is a psychologist who explains this really, really well. Actually, I think he's a psychiatrist. His name is Dr. Barish. And he is an expert in childhood shame, guilt, criticism. And back in 2012, he wrote this amazing article to do with children who are over-criticized as children. I'm literally just going to quote directly from his explanation because it's so spot on.
关于反馈。有一位心理学家把这一点解释得非常非常好。其实，我觉得他是一位精神科医生。他的名字叫巴里什博士（Dr. Barish）。他是童年羞耻、内疚和批评领域的专家。早在2012年，他写了一篇非常棒的文章，探讨那些在童年时期遭受过度批评的孩子。我打算直接引用他的解释，因为实在太贴切了。
In many families, overly criticized children and hypercritical parents get stuck in a cycle. Criticism and punishment lead to anger and defiance or secretiveness and withdrawal, and that just leads to more criticism and more defiance and more withdrawal. As these cycles escalate, parents feel increasingly justified in their criticism and the disapproval of their children, whereas the children. children for their part feel increasingly justified in their resentment and their defiance. Parents might say they never listen. The child says they just don't understand me. And they develop a poor relationship with feedback, beginning to become very sensitive to all forms of authority
在许多家庭中，过度受批评的孩子和吹毛求疵的父母会陷入一个循环。批评和惩罚导致愤怒与挑衅，或者隐瞒与退缩，而这又反过来导致更多的批评、更多的挑衅和更多的退缩。随着这些循环不断升级，父母对批评和不赞同自己孩子行为的做法感到愈发理所当然，而孩子们则在自己的怨恨和挑衅中感到愈发理所当然。父母可能会说他们从来不听话。孩子则说他们根本不理解我。他们因此与反馈建立了一种糟糕的关系，开始对所有的权威形式
or all situations in which feedback is provided. So, complex relationship, right? But again, if you are receiving a lot of criticism as a child, and that's such a negative, overwhelming experience, eventually you're only ever going to see feedback and criticism as a negative and overwhelming experience. And another outcome of this is of course self-criticism. You're probably like, oh yeah, wait, we haven't even talked about that yet. Like this is the missing piece. The reason being, and the reason I'm kind of quarantining this discussion between self-criticism and outside criticism is because we have done an episode on it before. I think it's episode 109. Why are we so hard on ourselves? So that one is more about.
或者所有提供反馈的情境变得异常敏感。所以，这是一种复杂的关系，对吧？但话说回来，如果你在童年时期接受了大量的批评，并且那是一种如此负面、压倒性的经历，那么最终你只会把反馈和批评永远视为一种负面和压倒性的经历。而这带来的另一个结果自然就是自我批评。你可能会想：哦对了，等等，我们甚至还没聊到这个呢。这就像是缺失的一块拼图。原因在于，我之所以把自我批评和外部批评的讨论隔离开来，是因为我们以前已经做过一期相关的节目了。我想那是第109期节目：为什么我们要对自己这么苛刻？所以那一期更多是关于。
self-criticism, you can listen to that after if that's more relevant. But yeah, it's really important to say when we feel repeatedly criticized, especially from someone that we care about, like a parent, like a partner, even like a teacher, eventually we can take up that role of the critic ourselves. We become the bully. We become the person who will not allow anything but perfection who can be almost emotionally abusive to ourselves. As one article from 2022 explained it, when we continually receive negative social evaluations or judgment, social rejection in the form of negative feedback, that can actually become very much ingrained so that we inevitably kind of project that pain onto ourselves alone. We don't need someone
自我批评，如果这与你更相关，你可以在那之后去听听。不过是的，非常重要的一点是，当我们感到自己一再受到批评，尤其是来自我们在意的人，比如父母、伴侣，甚至是老师，最终我们自己也会扮演起批评者的角色。我们变成了霸凌者。我们成了那个除了完美什么都不容许、对自己几乎达到情绪虐待程度的人。正如2022年的一篇文章所解释的那样，当我们不断接受负面的社会评价或判断，也就是以负面反馈形式存在的社会拒绝时，这实际上会深深地烙印在我们的脑海中，以至于我们不可避免地把这种痛苦独自投射到自己身上。我们根本不需要什么
on the outside saying, oh, I don't like you, I don't like this, you're doing this wrong, you look hideous, you're always going to be a failure, whatever. The criticism no longer comes from outside. It comes from, I don't know, like inside the house. You feel criticized enough that you become the critic. I just think we have enough to deal with in this world. That just, we cannot take up that role. We cannot be the one who shuts ourselves down before anyone else even has the opportunity to do it. We also, I think, miss out on valuable information when we develop an conversion to criticism. You know, feedback and criticism, we're going to get into the distinction. It can actually make us better. And that's something that I think you only learn the older you get.
外在的人跳出来说，哦，我不喜欢你，我不喜欢这样，你这做错了，你长得太丑了，你永远是个失败者，诸如此类。批评不再来自外部。它来自，我不知道，就像是来自屋子内部。你受到的批评已经够多了，以至于你自己成了那个批评者。我只是觉得，在这个世界上我们要应对的事情已经够多了。我们简直，我们不能承担那个角色。我们不能成为那个在别人甚至还没机会开口之前就把自己否定掉的人。而且我认为，当我们对批评产生反感时，我们也会错失有价值的信息。你知道的，反馈和批评，我们等会儿会讲到它们的区别，其实能让我们变得更好。这是你年纪越大才会懂得的道理。
And I've come to find that when we start to handle criticism from others more selectively and correctly, then we actually gain a lot of truth. When we begin to be quite light in our reception of criticism, our inner critic also begins to get a lot quieter as well. So you have these dual benefits. Not only does that inner critic in your own head begin to be silenced, you also begin to grow and your self-concept becomes more impenetrable. So it's not like every time you receive a correction or, you know, some feedback, it's like punching a hole into your self-concept, you can kind of hold it in your hands and take it for what it is. So I really want to talk through this healthy approach to criticism and how we can kind of, what's the word,
我渐渐发现，当我们开始更有选择性、更正确地处理来自他人的批评时，我们实际上收获了许多真相。当我们开始以轻松的心态去接受批评时，我们内心的批评者也会变得安静许多。所以你会有这双重好处。不仅你脑海里那个内心的批评者开始被噤声，你自身也会开始成长，你的自我概念会变得更加坚不可摧。所以这就好像，不是每一次你受到纠正或者某些反馈时，都像是在你的自我概念上凿出一个洞，你可以把它捧在手里，实事求是地接受它。所以我真的很想和大家探讨这种对待批评的健康方式，以及我们如何能够，怎么说呢，
kind of decide between the good stuff and the unnecessary stuff, what can be discarded from the criticism that we're receiving. We're going to talk about all of that and much, much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
在好东西和没必要的东西之间做出抉择，从我们所接受的批评中剔除掉哪些部分。在这段短暂的广告之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多精彩内容。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇奇怪怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with. with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends,
我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“两点”（Two Percent）。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会获得愚蠢的奖品。法则二，千万不要惹。她的朋友也一样。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新季的《女友们》中，
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个高产的雌雄大盗。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己动手。我说，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserved. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush
他会得到应有的惩罚。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什
didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here,
不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back At It）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代瘾品的节目。说清楚点，84年对我很重要，不只是因为瘾品。我随时都可以聊一整天瘾品，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，到目前为止，马克，这是我们讨论瘾品的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people. people in American history.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是黑人历史上最重要的一年之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难地学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖姆斯（Keer Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞恩·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于我们没有
realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me Keer games is we have real conversations about healing growth fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now.
意识到我们已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们盯着生活记分牌，生活变成了输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，还是你活着是因为害怕才做一个好人？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。加入我和吉尔·盖姆斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难地学习》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索《艰难地学习》，现在就收听。
If you want to break the spell that criticism has over you, you need to find the distinction between criticism and feedback. And I know I've been using those quite interchangeably, and it might seem easy enough, but I think a problem with being critiqued really begins to get out of control. when we conflate the two such that, you know, even when we receive helpful tips and tricks, they become really insulting in our minds because we're on high alert because we don't know the distinction. As annoying as it is, at some point you are going to screw up or do something wrong and you can continue to make that mistake despite people trying to help you and correct you.
如果你想打破批评对你施加的魔咒，你需要分清批评和反馈。我知道我一直把这两个词混着使用，而且这看起来可能很简单，但我觉得当被批评的问题真正失控时，往往是因为我们把这两者混为一谈，以至于，你知道的，哪怕我们收到有用的建议和技巧，在我们的脑海里它们也变成了莫大的侮辱，因为我们处于高度戒备状态，根本分不清它们的区别。尽管这很烦人，但在某些时候，你总会搞砸或者做错事，哪怕别人试图帮你和纠正你，你依然会一错再错。
And, you know, you could even jeopardize your relationship, jeopardize your job, jeopardize friendships or you can break the cycle and you can push back against the instinctual hostility we tend to have when we're criticized and make changes. I think seeing criticism as an opportunity rather than a finality rather than something you can't move past is quite liberating. But firstly, yes, we do need to know what we should be paying attention to what we, you know, versus what we can rightfully be frustrated by and upset at or just ignore. So let me give you the five essential differences between criticism and feedback. And I want you to think about a previous case in which you have received a criticism or a piece
而且，你知道的，你甚至可能危及你的感情、危及你的工作、危及友谊，或者你可以打破这个循环，去对抗我们面对批评时往往会有的本能敌意并作出改变。我觉得把批评视为一种机遇而不是终局，视为一种你可以超越的东西，是一件相当解放的事情。但首先，是的，我们确实需要知道自己应该关注什么，哪些是我们，你知道的，可以理所当然地感到沮丧和愤怒的，或者干脆忽略的。所以，让我来告诉你批评和反馈之间的五个本质区别。我想让你回想一个你曾遭受批评或收到某种
of feedback, whether it's from a boss or a friend or a family member and see which category it falls into. The biggest thing for me is that criticism is going to focus on what someone doesn't want you to do, but feedback is going to focus on what you can start doing. So for example, criticism might be like, well, I hate when you do that. I hate when you wear that. I hate when blah, blah, blah. Whereas feedback is like, oh, in the future, maybe you can wear more comfortable shoes.
反馈的过去案例，无论是来自老板、朋友还是家庭成员，然后看看它属于哪一类。对我来说最重要的一点是，批评会专注于别人不想让你做什么，而反馈则会专注于你可以开始做什么。例如，批评可能是：哼，我讨厌你那样做。我讨厌你穿那个。我讨厌你blablabla。而反馈则是：哦，将来或许你可以穿更舒服一点的鞋子。
In the future, maybe we could have this discussion a different way. Future focused. And that's the second part. Criticism is focused on the past. Criticism is focused on the future. what do we actually want to improve rather than getting really stuck in the weeds of past mistakes anyone who is only interested in going over and over and over the past as a way to make you feel bad isn't actually interested in seeing you grow criticism is also focused on weaknesses whereas feedback
以后，也许我们可以用另一种方式来讨论。专注于未来。这是第二部分。批评关注的是过去，而反馈关注的是未来。我们究竟想改进什么，而不是陷入对过去错误的纠缠中。任何只把一遍又一遍翻旧账当作让你难堪的方式的人，其实并不关心你的成长。此外，批评关注的是缺点，而反馈
is building up strengths so someone who gives you feedback might be like hey i really liked how you did it this way, but maybe you could do it better this other way, whereas criticism is, I hated how you did that full stop. That was terrible, that was bad, and you know, you should feel ashamed. This is your weaknesses without any room to really improve. And that's really the fourth point here. You can see how a lot of them really bleed into each other. Criticism is, you know, quite harsh and it deflates you. It makes you feel shallow, empty, bad about yourself. Feedback, although it might present you with stuff that you don't really want to acknowledge and you might not particularly like about yourself, it does inspire you and it does aim to make you better. Criticism says you are the problem. Feedback says we can make this better together. So that's the final distinction. Is it individual, in which case it's criticism, or is it collaborative in which the person may also be acknowledging their mistake?
则是在构建优势。所以给你反馈的人可能会说，嘿，我真的很喜欢你这样做的方式，但也许你用另一种方式能做得更好；而批评则是：我讨厌你那样做，句号。那太糟糕了，那很不好，你知道的，你应该感到羞耻。这是赤裸裸地指出你的缺点，却没有任何让人真正改进的空间。这其实就是第四点。你可以看到，其中很多内容其实是相互交织的。批评，你知道的，相当严厉，会让人泄气。它会让你觉得自己很肤浅、很空虚、对自己感觉很糟。而反馈虽然可能会呈现出你并不真想承认、甚至可能不太喜欢的自身缺点，但它确实能激励你，旨在让你变得更好。批评说：你就是问题所在。反馈则说：我们可以一起把这做得更好。所以，这就是最后的区别：它是针对个人的（这种情况下就是批评），还是协作性的（在这种情况下，对方可能也会承认自己的错误）？
You know, I always, I do think about this a lot in the work context because I think that as 20 year olds, that's where we get the most feedback. And I think about it like when your boss goes, oh, when your boss says to you, maybe I didn't communicate that as well as I should have. And they take some of the accountability and they realize that it's a joint mutual collaborative affair. That is when you know you have a really good boss. And that is when you know that you have someone who isn't just out to criticize you because of insecurity, frustration, anger without actually wanting you to get better. And that final point again is what really nails it for me. Yes, sometimes people will use examples from the past.
你知道，我一直在工作环境中经常思考这个问题，因为我认为，作为20多岁的年轻人，我们正是在那里获得最多的反馈。我经常这样想：当你的老板说，哦，也许我刚才没有把那件事沟通好，或者说得像我本应该做的那样好。他们承担了一部分责任，并意识到这是一项共同的、相互协作的事情。那就是你知道自己遇到了一位真正的好老板的时候。这也是你知道自己身边有这样一个人：他不仅仅是出于不安全感、沮丧或愤怒而想要批评你，而不是真的想让你变得更好。而最后这一点再次真正触动了我。是的，有时候人们会使用过去的例子。
They will question things that they'd like you to stop doing. But there is no point listening to criticism about something that you cannot improve or change because it shows that the person who is telling you those things really isn't interested in letting you show them otherwise. They are interested in saying you, fail. They're interested in scolding you like a child, but you cannot improve from that environment. You know, there have been papers written on this, especially when it comes to childhood and adolescents, that children who are scolded rather than give an instruction for what
他们会质问那些他们希望你停止的行为。但是，去听取那些你无法改进或改变的事情的批评是没有意义的，因为这表明对你说的那些话的人其实并不想让你向他们证明并非如此。他们只想说：你失败了。他们只想像训斥孩子一样训斥你，但在那种环境中你是不可能进步的。你知道的，这方面已经有很多相关的论文了，尤其是在童年和青春期研究方面：比起那些获得具体指导说明的孩子，那些仅仅遭到训斥的孩子
to do differently often end up feeling more intense shame, and it actually worsens the problem behavior in the first place, because again, it creates an environment where they're not given an alternative, you are not given an alternative other than this failure or this mistake. So I think the same goes for us in our 20s. You cannot become a better person through shame. You only end up policing yourself to become smaller when that's the case. And so when someone only wants to insult you or be emotional about something or take something out on you or is unrealistic, I actually don't think it's useful for you to listen to that. So make sure you can identify. the difference between feedback and criticism. Feedback is valuable, criticism is not.
往往会产生更强烈羞耻感，这实际上反而会恶化原本的问题行为，因为同样地，这营造了一种环境——他们没有被提供其他的选择，除了这种失败或错误之外，你没有别的选择。所以我认为我们在20多岁时也是如此。你无法通过羞耻感成为一个更好的人。在这种情况下，你最终只会不断自我审视和规训，让自己变得越来越渺小。因此，当一个人只想侮辱你、对某事情绪化、把气撒在你身上或不切实际时，我认为听取这些内容对你没有任何益处。所以，请确保你能识别反馈和批评的区别。反馈是有价值的，而批评则没有。
Now, if you are in a scenario where someone is, you can see giving them the benefit of the doubt, is attempting to give you feedback, but it's sounding distinctly like criticism, I think you do have a right to correct them and ask for clarification. And that clarification could be, what do you actually want me to do in the future? What is the room for improvement? What is the room for improvement, what in the future needs to change, what actions specifically, you're allowed to ask for more information because otherwise all that happens is you're frustrated, they're frustrated, nothing actually changes because you don't know what each other want. So that is my second biggest tip for handling criticism is to actually look for actionable things that you can do
现在，如果你处于这样一种情境中：对方——你可以看出本着给予对方信任的原则——正试图给你反馈，但听起来明显像是批评，我认为你完全有权纠正他们并要求澄清。这种澄清可以是：你实际上希望我将来怎么做？改进的空间在哪里？改进的空间在哪里，未来有哪些需要改变，具体是哪些行动？你有权要求获得更多信息，否则发生的情况只会是你感到沮丧、他们也感到沮丧，但实际上什么也没有改变，因为你们不知道彼此想要什么。所以，应对批评的第二大秘诀其实是寻找你可以付诸行动的事情，
and articulate to the person who is providing you with feedback why that's going to be important for you to know. Why, you know, maybe you don't have to say this component, but why, you know, the criticism is unhelpful, the feedback is helpful. The third component to dealing with criticism is really to try and detach and segment your reaction. Here's kind of what I mean by this. You are going to have two reactions with anything. The instinctual immediate reaction, which is often based in fear. It's based in insecurity and defensiveness. And then you wait 10 minutes, you wait half an hour, you wait an hour, and that smoke begins to fade. And what is revealed is your true feelings. Your second reaction is the one that you can trust. Because in that time,
并向给你提供反馈的人阐明为什么了解这一点对你很重要。为什么，你知道的，也许你不需要说出这一部分，但为什么，你知道的，批评是没有帮助的，而反馈是有帮助的。应对批评的第三个组成部分，实际上是尝试抽离并分段处理你的反应。我这话的意思是这样的。对于任何事情，你都会产生两种反应。第一种是直觉上的即时反应，通常基于恐惧。它基于不安全感和防御心理。然后你等上10分钟、半小时、一个小时，这种怒火开始消散。随之显现的才是你真实的感受。你的第二反应才是你可以信任的。因为在那段时间里，
your rational mind kind of switches back on and now there is space and there is distance for you to be heard and for that part of your brain to be heard. And often that's when you realize that this logical, often humble voice is the right one to listen to. The problem in my mind occurs, and I've definitely, definitely found myself in this situation when your illogical, instinctual reaction has been allowed to dominate and has been allowed free reign. And often that means that you jump the gun. You know, you bite back. You are dismissive.
你的理性思维会重新上线，这时才有了空间和距离，让你听到自己内心的声音，让大脑的那部分功能发挥作用。通常也正是在这个时候，你会意识到这个理性的、通常很谦逊的声音才是最应该听取的。在我看来，问题出现的情况是——而且我绝对、绝对发现自己曾陷入这种境遇——当你的非理性、直觉性反应被允许占据主导地位并被纵容时。通常这意味着你会反应过度。你知道的，你会回击。你会表现出不屑一顾。
You are angry. And later on, you wish that you'd held your time. That sometimes I think that I have a lot of grace for people who go through that. Sometimes it's unavoidable you are only human, but it can leave you worse off, especially when it becomes a habit. So my advice for overcoming this is to recognize that our reactions are often what hurt us more than the criticism itself and to actually have a system in place for how you're going to respond in those situations that can override your instinctual reaction. So this may be a series of strategies around staying silent, noting to the person that you're happy to discuss, but you are going to take time to respond and to think and you're not going to do so immediately. I also really recommend go for a walk
你会生气。而事后，你会希望自己当时能控制住情绪。有时候，我对那些经历过这些的人抱有很大的同情心。有时这是不可避免的，毕竟人非圣贤，但这可能会让你的处境变得更糟，尤其是当它成为一种习惯时。因此，我克服这一问题的建议是：认识到我们的反应往往比批评本身对我们的伤害更大，并真正建立一套应对机制，规定自己在这些情况下将如何反应，从而能够压制你的直觉反应。这可能是一系列围绕保持沉默的策略，向对方指出你很乐意讨论，但你需要花时间来回应和思考，而不会立即做出反应。我也强烈建议去散步
immediately after, not with your phone unless you want to call someone that you trust. And maybe that's actually better advice. You know, you need your phone to call someone, but you should get out of the house, you should detach from the situation physically in order to get the emotional distance as well, jump on the phone with someone you trust and talk about it. Talk about it because when we stew, when we isolate, when we ruminate, that often prolongs our negative reaction to criticism and it results in less improvement overall. So you do need to get out of your mind. You need to get out of that space. You need to get out of the repetitive thinking and either discuss it, or think through it in a productive way with someone that you trust,
立刻去，不要带手机，除非你想打给你信任的人。也许这其实是更好的建议。你知道的，你需要手机来打电话，但你应该离开家，在物理上与这个情境脱离，以便获得情绪上的距离。拿起电话打给你信任的人，聊一聊。聊一聊，因为当我们陷入内耗、孤立无援、反复咀嚼时，往往会延长我们对批评的负面反应，并导致整体上的改进减少。所以你确实需要跳脱出那个思维。你需要跳脱出那个空间。你需要摆脱重复的思考，要么去讨论它，要么与你信任的人以一种富有成效的方式将其思考透彻，
calm down for a second, and then return. I hear all these stories all the time of people who are criticized or given feedback and just go into a fury, do things that they regret and ruin their lives. You know where we see it a lot is with road rage. That is like a prime example. It's not just frustration. it's our ego and it's our aversion to feedback, to the honk of the horn,
冷静一会儿，然后再回来。我经常听到这样的故事：有些人受到批评或得到反馈后，直接怒火中烧，做出了让自己后悔的事，甚至毁了自己的生活。你知道我们经常在哪里看到这种情况吗？路怒症。这就是一个典型的例子。这不仅仅是沮丧，更是我们的自我（ego）以及我们对反馈、对按喇叭的声音、
to like, you know, the person getting frustrated with us. And people do the dumbest things trying to protect their egos and trying to assume that they are right. We aren't going to be those people. I'm sorry to say it. Hopefully that's not disappointing. But I do think that emotions have a beautiful place. They don't have a place when it comes to rash decision making,
对别人对我们感到不满的本能抗拒。人们为了保护自己的自尊心、为了自以为正确而做出最愚蠢的事情。我们可不做那样的人。很抱歉这么说。希望这不会让人失望。但我确实认为情绪有它美好的位置，但在做出仓促决策时，尤其是在这种性质的决策时，
especially of this nature. So it is okay to take some time and to segment those reactions. Identify the first reaction and then wait for the second reaction. Often as well, this is the time when you actually see that this feedback is actually an opportunity, not a threat. I also find that projecting almost a happy front to feedback makes it an easier pill to swallow. Feeling threatened by criticism is a passive response. it is a natural response it's the instinctual response right but being open being almost like artificially welcome to it almost cheery that is an active response and it brings back a sense of control like yes i'm opting into
它们可没有立足之地。所以，花点时间把这些反应分段处理是没有问题的。识别出第一种反应，然后等待第二种反应。通常情况下，这也是你真正发现这种反馈其实是一个机遇而非威胁的时刻。我还发现，在面对反馈时，几乎是表现出一种快乐的姿态，能让这颗苦药更容易吞咽。受到批评感到受到威胁是一种被动反应。这是一种自然反应，是直觉反应，对吧？但保持开放，几乎是像人工欢迎一样热切地接受它、近乎欢快地面对它，那是一种主动反应，它能带回一种掌控感——是的，我选择参与
this conversation i'm excited to learn i'm the one who wants the feedback can you see how that's a bit of a mindset shift away from this very dark hostile aversion avoidance to criticism so accepting graciously, recognize what's feedback, what's criticism, ask for the specifics so that you can actually improve, detach and be honest with yourself about whether you're going to be better off or worse off integrating what they've suggested. You know, you can't just shut down anything that's not praised because then you couldn't live in this society. And you're missing out on so much that is of value. You know, people do know more than us. People do notice things that we don't. So there is a knowledge there, there is a truth there, there is information there that is kind of a gift
这场对话，我很高兴去学习，我是那个渴望得到反馈的人。你能看出这是一种思维模式的转变吗？从那种非常黑暗、充满敌意的回避、逃避批评的心态，转变为：心怀感激地接受，识别什么是反馈、什么是批评，询问具体细节以便真正改进，抽离出来，并对自己开诚布公地评估：吸收他们的建议是会让自己变得更好还是更糟。你知道的，你不能仅仅因为一句话不是赞美就全盘否定，因为那样的话你将无法在这个社会上生存。而且你也会错失许许多多极具价值的东西。你知道的，人们确实比我们懂得多。人们确实能注意到我们忽视的事情。因此，那里蕴含着知识，蕴含着真理，蕴含着某种
at times. The final element of this that is worth exploring that we've touched on a little bit is really beginning to have a clear understanding of who deserves to give you feedback because there is an important difference between someone who loves you or who wants you to excel or who should be giving you instruction and, you know, for lack of a better word, a hater. This is something I manage a lot being someone who, I hate saying this, but I don't know, but who has an online presence, right? I have a job that is based on the internet. And it's something that people ask me a lot about when they find out that part of my job
有时堪称礼物的讯息。值得探讨的最后一部分——我们之前也稍微触及过——是真正开始明确界定：谁才配给你提供反馈。因为这里有一个重要的区别：一个爱你的、希望你优秀的人，或者本该指导你的人，与——恕我直言——一个纯粹的“黑粉”（hater）之间，存在着重要的区别。作为一个——我讨厌这么说，但我不知道怎么形容，不过我确实有网络影响力的人——我经常要处理这种情况，对吧？我的工作是以互联网为基础的。每当人们发现我工作的一部分
is making content or when a video goes viral or whatnot. they will always ask like how do you deal with the criticism how do you deal with the hate because you are going to get a lot of nastiness for the smallest things from very insecure people who i assume just get some kind of weird pleasure from being cruel or they want to make others feel the way that they've been made to feel in their lives maybe it's a little bit less lonely knowing that someone else is going through it if you want a really interesting study about this, there is one that is quite well known from 2014 and it basically looked at the interaction between trolling, cyberbullying and personality. And it found that amongst their 300 or so participants,
是制作内容，或者当某个视频病毒式传播等等时，他们总是会问我这个问题。他们总是会问：你是怎么应对批评的？你是怎么应对那些恶意的？因为你会因为最微小的事情而招致大量恶意，这些恶意来自于极度缺乏安全感的人，我猜他们只是从残忍中获得某种奇怪的快感，或者他们想让别人体验到他们在生活中曾感受过的对待。也许，知道别人也正在经历这一切，会让人感觉不那么孤独。如果你想看一项关于这方面的非常有趣的研究，有一项2014年的研究相当知名，它基本上探讨了网络喷子（trolling）、网络霸凌与人格之间的互动关系。研究发现，在他们大约300名参与者中，
mostly young people in their 20s, those who were like more likely to engage in hateful behavior online. And when I're talking like hateful in terms of like racism or sexism or homophobia, are more so like just trolling and just saying cruel stupid things, the people who are more likely to do that have a low self-esteem, some of the lowest that they were seeing in this cohort. But they also had really high levels of sadism. They enjoyed hurting others. So not the nicest people in the world.
主要是20多岁的年轻人，那些更有可能在网上参与恶意行为的人——当我们谈论这种恶意时，比如种族主义、性别歧视或恐同，更多的时候其实只是网络喷子式的、发表一些残酷愚蠢言论的行为——那些更有可能这样做的人具有很低的自尊心，属于他们在这个群体中看到最低的那一档。但他们同时也具有极高的虐待倾向。他们喜欢伤害别人。所以这可不是世界上最善良的人。
Definitely not those who we should trust to give us feedback. But yes, you get trolls and you will get people who don't understand you. And I went through this period around May last year. oh this year actually wow time flies um but where i was just getting a lot of new followers and new engagement and new listeners and it felt like every hour someone had an opinion that wasn't particularly nice some of them were really superficial and they were based on appearance like you need to fix your smile fix your clothes fix your skin lose some weight which was just like oh my god i'm going to be busy if i've got to do all those things but then there were others like you know i don't i don't like
绝对不是我们应该信任并向其寻求反馈的人。但是是的，你会遇到喷子，也会遇到不理解你的人。我在去年5月左右经历过这样一段时期。哦，其实是今年，哇，时光飞逝，嗯，当时我刚刚获得了大量的新粉丝、新的互动和新的听众，感觉好像每隔一个小时就有人对我不满，而且那些评价实在算不上友好。其中一些非常表面，甚至针对外表，比如：你需要修整一下微笑、整理一下衣服、改善一下皮肤、减减肥等等。当时我的感觉简直是：天哪，如果必须做完所有这些事情，那我可有得忙了。但接着还有其他的评价，比如：你知道的，我不喜欢
that you didn't include this perspective. I don't like that your microphone wasn't loud enough. I don't like the ads. And it was important for me to see that there is a distinction there. There was people who are like, no, I'm genuinely trying to be helpful. And then there are people like this woman who literally, this sticks in my mind. This woman was like, oh, I think you're money hungry and greedy. And that sticks in my mind. That person is not trying to be helpful. She's giving me an opinion on my character, not knowing me. And so the really valuable thing that I took away from this was, A, you have to be able to distinguish again the feedback and the criticism, but B, you actually just don't have to listen to everyone. And in fact, I don't think that you should
你没有包含这个视角。我不喜欢你的麦克风声音不够大。我不喜欢这些广告。对我来说，重要的是看出这两者之间存在区别。有一类人是真心实意想提供帮助的；而另一类人，就像这个女人——这句话简直深深印在我的脑海里——这个女人说：哦，我觉得你唯利是图、贪得无厌。这句话一直留在我脑海里。那个人根本不是想提供帮助。她在不了解我的情况下，对我的性格指手画脚。所以我从中汲取到的非常有价值的一点是：第一，你必须能够再次区分反馈和批评；第二，实际上你根本没必要听取每个人的意见。事实上，我认为你也不应该这么做，
because when you become a sponge for everything said about you, you begin to take on the behaviors, the opinions, the judgments, the expectations of others. You become a reflection of what others don't want you to be rather than who you want to be. So here is my final. reminder amongst this discussion, amongst our need to accept criticism, you have to remember that the only person whose opinion matters the most is yours. After that, you know, family and friends do come into it. I think you should listen to about 85 to 90% of what they have to say. Then of course, there are people who you're dependent on like your boss, your co-workers, your landlords maybe, people that you respect who don't know you very well, like a professor, maybe even a casual mentor.
因为当你成为一块海绵，吸收了关于你的一切言论时，你就会开始承载他人的行为、意见、判断和期望。你最终会成为别人不希望你成为的样子的反射，而不是成为你想成为的自己。所以，这是我在这次讨论中、在我们接纳批评的需求中给出的最后提醒：你必须记住，唯一最重要、最有分量的意见永远是你自己的。在此之后，你知道的，家人和朋友才会占据一席之地。我认为你应该听取他们所说内容的85%到90%。再然后，当然是你所依赖的人，比如你的老板、同事、房东，或者那些你不怎么熟悉但你尊敬的人，比如教授，甚至偶尔的导师。
And then at the bottom of the food chain, at the bottom of the ladder, are people who don't care about you, who don't know you, who are strangers, who are internet trolls, who are acquaintances, someone you met at a party once or twice. Those people, the feedback they give you, I think, is really helpful if it's cruel in nature. And as much as we are trying to keep an open mind and we want to grow through what we're going through,
而在食物链的最底层、阶梯的最底层，则是那些不关心你、不了解你、素不相识的人，网络喷子、泛泛之交、你在某个派对上见过一两次的人。对于这些人给你的反馈，如果本质上是恶意的，我认为大可不必理会。尽管我们一直在努力保持开放的心态，并且希望通过我们所经历的一切来成长，
we want to grow from what people have to say, this is my rule of thumb. If you wouldn't let this person sit at your dinner table, if you wouldn't welcome them into your house, if you wouldn't ask them for their advice, don't take their criticism. You are going to be doing yourself huge favour. You cannot let unnecessary judgments take over your mind
我们希望从别人的话语中汲取成长，但这才是我的经验法则：如果你不会让这个人坐在你的餐桌旁，如果你不会欢迎他们进屋，如果你不会向他们征求建议，那就不要接受他们的批评。你在帮自己一个大忙。你不能让不必要的评判占领你的大脑，
because it's like a virus. It's like a sickness. So truly, if you are placing too much value on the opinions of others who do not care about you, who will never care about you, you, you end up having, firstly, less room to hear your own inner voice, but also less space to actually hear from those who care about you. Because the loudest voice in the room is sometimes going to be the meanest, and that is going to be the person who actually isn't trying to help you.
因为这就像病毒一样。这就像一场疾病。老实说，如果你把过多的价值寄托在那些不关心你、也永远不会关心你的外人身上，你最终会发现：首先，你倾听自己内心声音的空间变少了；其次，你倾听那些真正关心你的人的空间也变少了。因为房间里声音最大的人往往也是最恶毒的那个，而那个人其实并不是为了帮助你。
It's important that you know the difference, and that you actually have space mentally, cognitively, socially to flourish without the shame, the embarrassment, the insecurity of listening to what every person on the street has to say because I don't think those are fertile soils from which to grow. So in summary, when we're talking about how to handle criticism, I do want you to truly commit to seeing feedback as a good thing. Don't try and fight against it. But also do be aware of when, you know, judgments are unusual or cruel or when, again, they're just not actionable because I don't think that person is actually committed to your growth than to your success.
重要的是你要知道其中的区别，并且在精神上、认知上、社交上真正拥有空间去蓬勃发展，而不必承受那种因聆听街上每个人的言论而带来的羞耻感、尴尬和不安全感，因为我不认为那是能够成长出肥沃土壤的地方。所以总的来说，当我们讨论如何处理批评时，我确实希望你真正致力于将反馈视作一件好事。不要试图去抗拒它。但同时也要意识到：当评判异乎寻常或带有恶意时，或者说，当它们根本无法付诸行动时，因为我认为那样的人其实并不致力于你的成长和成功。
There are definitely questions you should ask yourself when it comes to whether this person is someone I respect enough to listen to, whether they are actually here to be constructive or whether they're not. And you do have to kind of answer those questions for yourself. But if you can also try and find a way to segment your reaction and find a way to emotionally regulate and process criticism before it overrules the irrational logical part of your brain, I think that is also an amazing, amazing tool. Detach from the situation.
当你判断这个人是否是你足够尊重、值得去倾听的对象时，当你想知道他们到底是来给出建设性意见还是另有所图时，确实有一些问题你应该问问自己。对于这些问题，你必须自己给出答案。但是，如果你还能设法找到一种方法来分段处理你的反应，并在批评压倒你大脑中非理性的、逻辑的部分之前，找到一种情绪调节和处理批评的方法，我认为这同样是一个惊人的、绝佳的工具。从情境中抽离出来。
Find your calm place. Detach from the situation physically. And then return. Because criticism is harsh. It does feel like rejection. It does feel naturally threatening. So if you are someone who is struggling with taking things on board, really do get in the habit of practicing how to disconnect and remove yourself from the emotional component of a scenario like this one.
找到让你平静的地方。从物理层面上抽离出当时的情境。然后再返回。因为批评确实很严厉。它确实让人感觉像是一种拒绝。它确实天然地让人觉得充满威胁。所以，如果你是一个在全盘接受事情时感到挣扎的人，请务必养成练习如何断开连接、让自己从这种情境的情绪成分中抽离出来的习惯。
I really do hope that you have enjoyed this episode. I think that is all that I have time for today. I've been rambling. I've been rambling about criticism, about internet trolls. What's new? I love to talk about it. I love to just like, you know, put some flourishes of that in there. And I do just want you to know, like, it's okay to not,
我真的非常希望你们会喜欢这一期节目。我想这就是我今天所有的录音时间了。我一直在东拉西扯。我一直在漫谈批评、漫谈网络喷子。这有什么新鲜的？我就是喜欢聊这些。我就是喜欢在里面加点那种点缀。我只是想让你知道，其实没关系——
it's okay to not want to accept the things that people say to you that sometimes feel harsh. So if it's something that you're trying to adapt to, you have taken an amazing first step and I really do wish you the best of luck, whatever environment this is in. If you want a follow up to this episode, if there is something else around this that we have not discussed that you think people should know, please feel free to reach out to me at That Psychology Podcast. We are always taking episode suggestions all the time, all hours of the day.
没关系，如果你不想接受那些有时让你觉得严厉的话。所以，如果你正在努力适应这一点，你已经迈出了惊人的一步，无论你身处什么环境，我都真心祝你好运。如果你想要这一期节目的后续，如果你觉得周围还有其他我们没有讨论过、大家应该了解的内容，请随时通过《那门心理学播客》（That Psychology Podcast）与我联系。我们随时随地都在接收节目建议，一天24小时不间断。
So if there is a topic you want to hear, please, again, we would love to hear from you. make sure that you are following along on Apple Podcasts or Spotify and leave us a five-star review. It would really make our day. Wherever you are listening, we read them all and we appreciate them all. I'm saying we, it's just me. I appreciate them all. I love them all. And again, thank you for listening.
所以，如果你有什么想听的话题，请再次联系我们，我们非常期待听到你的声音。确保在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或Spotify上关注我们，并给我们留下五星好评。这真的会让我们的一整天都充满阳光。无论你在哪里收听，我们都会阅读每一条评论，并且感谢每一位听众。我一直在说“我们”，其实只有我一个人。我感谢所有人。我爱所有人。再次感谢大家的收听。
Until next time, stay safe, stay kind. Please be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
直到下期节目，注意安全，保持善良。请对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和构建适应力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将作为快乐、充实、更健康的人从另一端走出。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it
收听《2%》。即苹果播客、IHeart Radio应用或任何你获取播客的平台上的“TWO percent”。收看《回顾某个播客》（Look Back at a Podcast）。对于1979年来说，那对我和我而言都是一个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay），我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的，
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
你正在收听的是由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难学习法》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去这么做，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听“Learn the Hard Way”。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我整个人惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《深陷爱河》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。